merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
madame la Première ministre les classes
moyennes ne croient plus et n'écoutent
plus ceux qui les déposent c'est en ces
termes si jusque le géographe Christophe
Guy lui s'exprimait cette semaine dans
un grand quotidien c'est une
illustration parfaite du ressenti des
Français à la mise en place forcée des
zones affaiblissement mobilité notre
groupe ici au Sénat l'a rappelé il y a
quelques jours lors d'un débat que nous
avons souhaité après la mise en place
chaotique des ZFE du Grand Paris à
Toulouse en passant par Strasbourg ni
sous Toulon nous y avons défendu une
vision équilibrée entre le tout voiture
que nous récusons et le
jusqu'au-boutisme environnemental qui
voudrait supprimer tous les véhicules
les Français sont-ils informés que 40%
d'entre eux vont devoir dans les
prochaines années amener leur véhicule à
la casse non